une production du studio sfr bienvenue
au sens fait là est reparti le podcast
on parle de ce qu'on veut avec nos
invités dati site des fonds par le rôle
des fois non j ph canton avec moi d'une
plante sa est coté cette semaine ouais
ça amène et des séquences assez
aujourd'hui exactement on est commandité
par
les gars ne met pas plein oui c'est vrai
cette semaine sans filtre et présenté
par vegan n'est pas plat écoutez et
regardez problème c'est l'entreprise que
j'ai avec ma blonde
on a un site web à les voir là dessus on
est sur facebook and suivent sur
facebook vegan n'est pas plane sur toute
la ligne
on a des plats surgelés au casse-croûte
boucherville en ce moment on espère être
dans d'autres cosco prochainement on
vous garde à l'affût bâti et au
leadership parce qu'on peut l'acheter en
ligne
ouais on peut l'acheter en est une vraie
question bon et on peut l'acheter en
ligne surveillants des plates points
comme on va peut-être un code promo pour
nous un instant par cast sort demain je
pense que j'ai le temps de régler seuls
mes lâchetés cas les lâchetés de prix
est bon vous le savez on parle de
véganisme souvent on s'en fait le
podcast c'est un sujet qui m'habite dôme
est végétarien écoutez paul maxim's
écouter quand c'est de sensibiliser ou
non mais si vous l'êtes être allé voir
mes potes comme merci cette semaine on a
reçu au podcast de notre ami thomas
nowacki qui fait son propre casque qu'il
enregistre ici fait qu'on le creusot on
le voit souvent
puis un gars avec qui j'aime vraiment
beaucoup avoir des discussions avant ou
après ces podcasts souvent au cello
studio pis puis on jase tango
super intéressant super passionnés
parpaing dans fargo qui enfin
intéressante avec de parler on a abordé
le podcast en parlant du cinéma direct
on a en parlé beaucoup de cinéma donc si
ça vous intéresse ou si vous de
découvrir un peu plus le cinéma peut
avoir des suggestions peut-être de films
à écouter on parle parle de beaucoup de
fans des films qu'ils ont marqué les
films qu'ils ont ils ont changé vous
avez aimé le cinéma
enfin que pour tout amateur de ce médium
de cet art je recommande d' addiction
on eu un bon débat autour du film de
joker film qui était marquant cette
année le film sur ce personnage de
batman le joker qui est qui soit cette
année avec joaquin phoenix faut-il et j
oui qui a acquis un bon débat parce
qu'on avait tous les deux
interprétations puis des opinions
finalement mais quand même des maîtres
allemands opposés sur sur le sujet mais
ça a été intéressant de creuser
je pense qu'on était un microcosme de la
réception de ce fait mais là non
seulement parce qu'il ya eu il ya eu un
qui va j'ai eu un débat autour de ce
thème là puis on a eu ce débat là avec
lui autour de cette table puis après
sony complètement dévié le sujet vers
une section d'une transition vraiment
seamless vous allez remarquer en fait je
vous remarquerez même pas qu'à qu'on
change le sujet tellement que ça ce
naturel mais tellement être un passionné
de la sexualité de parler de sexe de q
finalement puis on ne pouvait pas éviter
le sujet avec lui fait qu'un baladeur
partie on a parlé un petit peu abordé ce
thème là on ne parle pas des graphies de
l'impact sur la société différente
les diverses manières de vivre sa
sexualité qui se taisent pas intéressant
donc on remercie d'être venu ici
si on espère que les messieurs sinon
ouais ben écoutez laisser des
commentaires participer à discussion on
a eu des fois où ce que je crois qu'on a
le plus débat dessus sur le 50 podcast
fait que
participatif qui ont évidemment que puis
là je vous dise aux obstacles sans
filtre je sais que d être extrêmement
intelligent mais les débats c'est
vraiment plus pertinent quand c'est fait
dans le respect piquant sépare
respectueux on les lit pop et on
participe pas vraiment non plus à
conversation fait amener votre poing
dans le respect ça va me faire plaisir
de le lire puis optimalement d'y
répondre
laissez-nous labo niveau à notre chaîne
laissez-nous des commentaires les
seniors times up sinon aurait été une
sur balle à dos laissez nous un
commentaire aussi sur les plateformes de
streaming
ça fait son bout de chemin sans plus
attendre bon bah tu y as tu raques
[Musique]
maman à l'eau yes merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté d'être là c'est un repli la
table s'est tournée pour toi tu es du
côté de l'invité du sans filtre oui mais
tu es aussi deux côtés de l'invité de
ton pas de casse à toi notamment la
vague c'est comme c'est comme votre
podcast sauf qu'on est juste deux il ya
des codes des côtes
bon y'a personne vous sûr mais aussi des
invités qui était cool dernièrement et
j'ai la semaine passée en torchis martin
mac d'iphone et études disponibles
tempétueux 7 juin c'est un pécule je
sais de quoi pour me pour m'obliger à la
semaine prochaine pas génial ça va être
disponible ici me mettre la pression
messieurs alors c'est cool c'est cool
c'est qu'on peut éviter le monde à aller
écouter le tombeau de casquettes
enregistrés dans mon studio aussi
quelque chose que dans des podcasts des
fois tu abordes mais j'ai l'impression
que les invités embarque potence dans ce
que tout d'abord le moi je veux sauter
là dedans parce que nous votons ont très
plat tu mets tu parle souvent du cinéma
oui c'est un passionné de cinéma
je me suis dit qu'en arrivant ici je
voulais parce que taulard de rgo aussi
qu'ils aiment se faire des pas pour
faire des listes mais avoir des tops des
moments forts dans ton que l'offre aux
gens que j'aime et ils ont des listes
souvent c'est un truc qui me qui me
déplaire plus du cinéma ça quel point
les prix loin les sont si importantes
j'ai l'impression que pour sa musique et
surtout pas son sens de l'humour
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment c'est
très 1er classe le cinéma c'est très qui
est la mère céline notes sont si
importants tous les films son côté et je
suis vraiment telle inverse dans mon
frère pascal qui l'absolu lui l'éditeur
lui fait du cinéma
moi je poste merci je vous fixe des mots
mais aussi qui restait qu'à sa manière
des animaux par des cinéastes ont vu
tous les fils moi aussi c'est un
caractère que l'apport des cinéastes on
me suis juste un gars chez eux qui
redéfinit le des opinions bien ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui me
plante jusqu'à dix fois vingt fois plus
de femmes comment
tout ça deux fois plus de films que tout
le monde met d'ailleurs ce matin
parlant des prix y ont sorti les
nominations des oscars
oui je le pignon là dessus djoko est en
tête avec 11 des menaces et oui c'est
bon que les mauvais films et les
nominations puis qu'il est bon film soit
oubliée par les oscars
parce que les oscars ce qu'on observe
tout c'est souvent ça depuis 30 ans si
les bons réalisateurs le fun souvent pas
par exception c'est pas la mer films qui
sont récompensés son histoire est
compensée pour leur carrière
il faut un super film il ya dix ans nous
optons ils font un film correct qui sont
récompensés pour ce phénomène fait si
ils font un super film ils se font au
bout d une couple de fois par un succès
populaires comme shakespeare en amour
c'est juste cette année aux golden
globes meilleur film s'est invitée
gagner qui je n'ai même pas vu métier
selon selon les dires de tous pour le
plus grand film de temps les gens à
l'halloween les gens aiment la gagner
c'était peut-être nous avait réalisé à
rethel gagne
j'en doute et où dixit peut-être mais ça
fait super film qui flatte à les watts
sont contents de la victoire
les gens qui votent les oscars sont
extrêmement vieux cd vendus en accession
qu'un film comme en que james key et
voici la réalité de deux juifs qui ont
grandi à new york où il essaie de
changer ça par exemple parce que devrait
jamais changé et est passé cinq ans pour
gagner un prix je dirais personnes trip
sur n'est vraiment patient dans une
église mon trip si on est fan parce que
sa 10e touché de larissa devrait ça doit
toucher les gens tu vois dans la culture
un bon film qui dispose ça gagne les
escarres un bon film tu le vois dans les
films dix ans plus tard se voit que le
temps des fêtes le score 6 i déjà joker
un comique joker qui est une reprise qui
est un hommage à taxi driver s'est fait
battre par hugin as
alors si c'est ça les oscars sont
toujours en retard et c'est normal que
les producteurs et que les gens qui
donnent de l'argent films seront en
retard aux artistes et à la peuplaient
je n'ai qu'un artiste qui crée un stress
and haas corps amazone sweden moi j'ai
convaincu que oui parce que si elle a
gagné 2 à la grille en nascar début
vingtaine l'inde après elle était
nominée et quelques-uns des [ __ ]
maintenant et des oublis
elle a même pas 30 ans puis general
mills ajoutant rien de rien à quoi il
nous faudra une joue que les gens se
déplacent ce terminée c'est fou ce
harper féministe un come-back avoir 32
c'est un combat 30-12 ya déjà trente
deux ans savent même pas ce qu'ils
veulent faire
j'ajoute de google ça fait un petit bout
qu on n'est pas venu le temps depuis
c'est un autre chez nous ils ont signé
je sais pas s'il ya les yeux rien aux
états unis si on vote pour voter simple
les gens les plus heureux c'est moche
convaincu je suis convaincu que c'était
assez consommatrices savourer ça se
pourrait en fait je les tiens pas un job
mais ça se pourrait très bien que dans
une fois que le mystère existe plus de
101 à la somme en une dépression parce
que c'est parce que c'est des centaines
de millions de gens qui m'ont vu nu sans
mon accord ça fait mal je crois vraiment
vraiment que aux états unis ctu très
particulier qui peut contrôler de
sexualité plus là l'autre là pour
contrôler quelques temps un peu voler ça
ça brise tout maintenant c'est moi qui
publie une photo sur instagram que tu
montres tes fesses je crois que c'est
sûr ils le public personne qui la bonne
voie la madonna l'a fait toute sa
carrière
messahel c'était ma sexualité c'est moi
qui décide étaient les fortes six mois
on a vu le dessin de kim kardashian ça
complètement réunies sa carrière une
famille riche à tous le deuxième a
proposé aucune effectivement je sais pas
s'il dit jouer un personnage quand
j'imagine que c'est des belles parce que
c'est débile que dans la tête des
producteurs et des spectateurs vu qu'on
le venu tout seul en tête
j'ai fait une explication pourquoi le
m'était tombée c'est que hal est une
star de cinéma dans l'imaginaire
collectif une star de cinéma c'est censé
être le truc le plus
je ne tiens plus je resterai jamais une
star de cinéma qu'on veut complimenter
quelqu'un du tar sands une star de
cinéma ds ce qui est particulier c'est
dans ces photos le la de n'importe
quelle fille qui montre une photo de ses
seins sont qu art de n'importe qui qui
vient du même pascal wanou le roi l'a
fait est que c'est ce qui a enlevé le
mythe de nos yeux ces cas à cette grande
star l'a7 millionnaire cette fille qui
était dulic fait des tapis rouge
alors johnny sent obligé de monter ça
comme n'importe qui est le plus comique
à la même dit l'une des raisons pourquoi
la voyez cette route c'est sain c'est
que je voulais pas que mon homme se
masturbe sur la pornographie alors je
préférais mon corps allait même me direz
pas promet même complexe que nous d'un
autre côté c'était brillant pour être
utilisée pour des jeux comme vous gagne
ouais
juste des d'actionner d'assumer ce que
tu fais de deux sphères ouais mais oui
ça liquéfie désolé c'est pas facile mais
ce qu'une envie à schmidt - mais c'est
la main à dire qu'à faire autant
s'il ya des gens qui dit moi je m'assume
mais tu fais tu as une pote d'équitation
mais si la situation ne se répéterait
pas à 20 secondes citation si c'est une
grosse photo le ton pénis qui circulait
de serre est issu de la faire
disparaître ou trois gardes
mais n'est ce pas ce que tu peux pas la
faire moi je produis je pense que
mettons au québec on a un bon exemple
béatrice martin coeur de pirate c'est
nous du camp cndd sont sortis le faut
que sa carrière commençait à enlever ses
noces je pense pas que c'était nous qui
avait leaké je crois que c'était faux
sur ce terrain si c'est une des photos
de l qui est fait sur ce thème des siens
car après les jeux super 3g
j'ai fait ce maintenant et je peux pas
les enlever ne le parle j'ai des photos
de moi poil sur internet on l'a on l'a
quand même pas si vite oubliées au
lombard oui ça passait justement elle a
fait toi j'ai fait ça c'est un mais
c'est quoi tu mets une espérance une
star au québec tandis que j'ai fourni un
dossier des gens en nouvelle zélande qui
sont glissés différence est planétaire
ouais mais ce que ça change du temps et
aussi je reviens mon premier argument
c'est qu'au québec on oublie dans les
films maintenant américain populaire de
plus de 5
dans ce dernier film populaire avec des
synthés titanic depuis le film à gros
budget avec des femmes nues vraiment des
blockbusters loin je pense à aucun le
dernier systémique vient depuis un film
à gros budget dans le but de vendre des
billets de cinéma qui auraient des
femmes nues c'est vrai qu'il ya
publicité vraiment au cinéma ce que dans
le game of thrones en avaient la mine
témoin
ouais mais tu vois quand c'est devenu
mainstream millions et crissements
enlever cet aspect l'autre chose c'est
fou ce qu'ils ont réalisé que le monde
l'écoutait pour vrai ayant fait à quelle
heure on peut pas ce que j'ai déjà lu
ici c'est que c'est une manière de
vendre les films en chine et au moyen
orient
comme elle sait s'ils n'ont cessé
censure est justement comme la taupe a
vu dernier fait non je pense parce que
j'ai pas de 17 ans et enfin faut serrer
la ceinture et j'ai toujours été que
c'était toujours été des films pour
enfants entre eux c'est le bien contre
le mal c'est après l'âge de 14 ans
décroche du bien contre le mal
une fois que voit-on pas une chose de
mauvais leçons à qui mieux
les deux mais quand même à devoir ddv
souvent ces malades jamais revu le film
il y en ad oui j'ai 28 ans je demande à
qui je trouve sur star wars manière
bêtement irrationnelle en fait parce que
star wars
je pense que depuis le début les gens
une vision complètement mythique d'aidé
star wars original
épisode 4 5 6 comme si c'est des films
parfait comme c'étaient des le film
parfaitement ces défis mais parfait
c'est ce qui est génial c'est du film
très imparfait était un niveau plus haut
niveau que celle de qui rendent une fois
encore de porte parce que le fait que
mon niveau rien dans ce casque c'est la
blague c'est
penser c'est lui qui disait oui ça ils
sont habillés dans les centres urbains
en y voyant ce casse parce que c'est
comme la job tout les figurants et des
stormtroopers gagner partout d'un
logiciel parce qu'il voyait jamais rien
depuis tout le monde le site de ce thème
les animaux penser que transférer
nouvelle tu es allé gagner ses lecteurs
que faisait fait obi-wan noter que
l'acteur était le cas ce qu'a laissé si
les c'est quoi ce genre d'affaires
réputé lire je veux juste mon chèque de
paye en plus jamais entendre parler de
ce fait mieux évidemment ça s'arrêtait
là ça va être un avis a été le plus
grand paquebot ce tube ça complètement
changé le cinéma c'est comme ça a changé
la manière dont on faisait des films à
gros budget c'est parce qu'avant scellé
les studios investir une grands films
d'auteur les parents et les dires des
routeurs et les femmes de la même
d'après star wars c'est comme qui ont
investi dans les scènes d'action avec
cet art cette courbe le toujours la même
date ces puissants du film l'été soul
jazz ça change et consolide légèrement
[Rires]
pris le cas c'était deux grands amis il
semblerait que tout changer c'est
absolument des bons films qui sortent
pâles et élitiste lilloise et mes films
de série b et avec jazz tous les baby
boomers sont en vacances n'ont rien à
faire ça change le salon du cinéma mais
c'est uniquement les amplis les pour
laquelle les gens aiment stowers un
attachement émotif nostalgique
à une certaine époque moi ça a été
car j'étais jeune mes frères m'ont fait
d'écouter les vieux star wars piles et
la trilogie 1 2 3 de sortie qui est bon
c'était pas bon mais à l'époque je
voyais pas compte que c'est pas bon
parce que ce n'est pas comme dans le
monde avec la musique c'est vrai que
c'est une objection à une bonne scène
avec la musique c'est vrai que la
musique est bonne
j'adore que le
qui est le petit mot qui marque le
premier s'appelle les brigands jean oui
il ya c'est celle de l'air sur les taux
belges à faire la sale et genre de rôle
ces jeux ne riez pas c'est déjà
desservies et tous les juifs à ma fille
ce fait voler alors je tortue voici les
images c'est mc call il fait leaf et
alizée chaleur et un énorme film un très
grand film puis plus tard sa carrière
tekken en deux week-ends 1 2 3 au dessus
des restes trouvés mais chèque de paye
de tecla où ils sont bien plus haut que
la carrière de l'allemand pour un acteur
les trois tekken réunissent prendre en
chine doit même un pour un je compare
les époques avec ou sans inflation de
calcul prenant bref the town a plongé au
sida dans l'univers puis à y voir un peu
le pied plus loin la mythologie le
vélociste je sais c'est carrément côté
geek et carambar culte et que tu vois
les nouveaux était rien je me dis qu'on
les écoute j'ai des devoirs faute au
regard de la mythologie de truc en plus
qui contrôle gucci avec ton ouais je
sais pas on n'est pas en fait pas un
plaidoyer pro je décroche de star wars
c'est on les américains si un empire
c'est un état bilingue pour ce foot là
un des trucs les plus populaires ce soit
un homme à la guerre puis un homme à la
rébellion aussi et alors que se
concevoir que je devrais si les états
unis s'est empressé l'enfance nos labels
sichi irakien
reste une des quotidiens c'est ça pour
vrai mais ridicules sont devenus ce qui
était au départ une critique du nazisme
c'est au début le premier star wars
c'est une critique du nazisme d'hervé
d'opel en allemagne
mais le c'est devenu une espèce de
métaphores qui devenue un empire
américain
ce curieux je décroche on savait aussi
que premier star wars s'y prête me
calquer sur paris j'ai pas vu le cas
j'imagine que c'est quelqu'un aussi sur
beaucoup de films de chevalier petit
lutin grand guide des femmes de japonais
de sa morale qui tue mais t'es juste
premièrement le casque puis
l'habillement stress amoureux mais mais
aussi toute leur part mon histoire mais
moi je n'ai pas vu les sabres à klaus
qui le grand parallèle c'est la relation
de ces tropez où le petit robot dans le
film espèce de deux comiques font des
choses mais ça pour dire que ces films
lequel sont vendues à l'étranger mais je
veux pas se voiler la face il y avait
quand deux filles ça dure points 5 5
c'est vrai a été censuré en chine au
revoir aux habitants de fait pourquoi
cinq 5 ans c'est clair que justement il
est plein décisions qui sont prises pour
plaire et c'est sûr à la plus grande
froisser personne la plus à m'en passer
paquet mais le compliment qui se vendent
déjà dans le ventre c'est avec ces deux
jeunes filles de lebbeke sont vos coupes
est ce la guerre par contre est aussi
l'idée que dans la vie un bon côté un
mauvais côtés de makelele bonganga plus
les deux filles le bec en des deux
filles c'est vraiment genre faut qu'il
faut qu'ils vainquent y porte attention
ce pratique
non vraiment ça peut être deux temps que
le creusement chaque oeil aux perches
mais les deux mêmes qu'aux américains
puis le procès se disait tous les films
de spielberg sont des métaphores
deuxième guerre mondiale
ah ouais
servier sait tous les films speybrock
ans ou 10 north bay le but a été marqué
par le divorce de son père c'est par an
plus tôt et tout l'apport des films de
spielberg ont marqué par le divorce ou
sont marqués par la famille tout le
temps mettons jazz c'est un enfant que
je pense qu'ils ont un peu peur la
relation de ses parents comment
s'appelle le fameux rencontre troisième
type sont barry vire fou puis il lâche
sa famille pour un projet catch me if
you can c'est un gars qui quitte sa
famille tout en le divorce par son film
sur la guerre mondiale ça reste
quelqu'un qui doit les chercher un
enfant télé sonnerait comme un enfant
[Musique]
c'était vraiment c'est tout le temps
dans les films c'est très justement
manichéen de ses traits blancs et noirs
bon le bond de valve pile la seule la
seule juge de la seule à vraiment pas la
seule mais thil l'exemple premier du du
mal peur qu'on a dans l'histoire récente
de l'humanité s'est éclaté dernièrement
de lantier tactile 00h10 elithis aux
femmes sont même préféré de spielberg
pour ces symboles c'est la guerre des
monnaies qui lui disait ça aussi c'est
la plus belle analogie deuxième guerre
mondiale c'est lagarde et moi j'ai eu un
flash sur internet qui dit ça va me
disait qu'ils faisaient plus vie écrit
d'église vie lui qui beaucoup sur des
films lui disait que justin métaphore du
fascisme
sans doute pas jazz c'était la liesse
qui disait que c'était le si on veut sa
métaphore où ça se passerait en
allemagne nazie le monde sait les
allemands et les requins qu'on ne voit
pas c'est très important ne revoit
jamais c'est le mâle celi juifs alors
tout ce qu'il gèle c'est l'histoire de
trois hommes deux classes différentes
qui se réunissent contre l'ennemi commun
qui était un plus qui s'est passé ici
les juifs laïques ainsi pas que
les juifs
est ce que pour pour convaincre des gens
de faire le mal il faut que tu as un
ennemi commun sous tend ce tome c'est sa
mère qui a fait 33 les immigrants latino
c'est cet ennemi en pis apprenez ni
qu'on ne voit pas après les demies
qu'ils peuvent vraiment vraiment la part
des gens qui disent fort qu'il est non
non jamais rencontrés ils vont jusqu'au
c'est quoi mais vu ça prend un an et
demi qu'on ne voit pas comment déjà tu
vois pas le requin ne vois pas le mal
métaux peur de lui et unis pour aller
contre lui c'est vraiment une bonne
analyse
c'est ça c'est sûr mais des fois des
fois c'est dans les
slavoj zizek c'est dans l'est dans l'est
les analyses de l'est sur analyse films
dont le des fois on part vraiment champ
gauche complètement puis dans certains
cas j'y adhère - mais dans des cas comme
celui là c'est clair que ça fait pas que
blanc qui bloquent des stocks on peut
analyser de manière plus largement qui
découvrir des symboles et mettons encore
aujourd'hui de 15 ans non moi je pense
que oui encore aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
le film noir que ce serait plutôt aux
parasites symbolique mais c'est long je
pense qu'une fable on parle pas de blog
post non merci
symbole c'est quasiment un captain
america ces jeux seul petit hic que ce
fait que c'est même pas caché
fonctionnement derrière quoi que ce soit
le métier ou un requin qui représente
une cause sociale
le gué savez le captain america n'est il
pas caché le bail loin mais cache s'est
faite encore l'université sur les
lectures de la bible dans le fond cette
déduction tiens je me dis tu dis qu'on
laisse a coûté à peu
cette passation on lisait la babe non
mais c'est la chose la plus passionnante
lire la bible hirsch est la bible pour
venir parler pendant deux ans qu'un
groupe à l'église
non mais non mais c'est pas le point de
vue croyant le point d'un point de vue
chrétien d'un point de vue ont cédé
comprendre c'est quoi ça ils lisent la
bible est complète mais il abordait avec
une salle et par les églises
ce qui est extraordinaire religion c'est
que tu peux avoir dans la branche que tu
as lu dans des églises qui sont plus
intellectuel des églises qui sont plus
dans ce spectacle mais la plupart des
églises c'est exactement ce qu'ils font
ils lisent un passage de la bible et en
discutent entre eux pour ça que ma
course déroulé à l'église pixels mais
c'est le film sur superman man of steel
ticket reçu d'autres femmes a étudié a
commis neuf stella mais la vie n'est pas
l'épreuve
il disait ce film-là est cramé bourré de
références et bibliques et théologiques
le dit c'est l'analyse avec du point de
vue chrétien dépit du préfet là-dessus
je passe je rappelle qu on a fait
travailler des sessions se fait une
analyse chrétienne de robocop un très
bon cop c'est le christ qui renaît
pipeline sainte-cécile transposer le
jésus mais ces pipelines sinaman il est
à présent qui marche sur l'eau c'est la
manière que le plein est fait
pis pcsi si l'on sait conscience et
consiste selon eux robocop ces règles
qui votent series des bouffes ce que ce
sera beaucoup beaucoup qui a des trois
tirs sur des pauvres parce que ça va
s'arrêter de voler pour manger c'est
quand même génial que j'illustre est si
je revenais ideye ou le poste de police
s'en prend pompe
je veux le dire est qu'il ya des pauvres
qui mange qui volent nos rétines depuis
quitté ce bas les pauvres il voulait
révolutionnaire qui voulait faire la
révolution à palestine et enlever les
romains et louise non parce que j'ai
compris de jésus cia mais peu importe
qu'elle et lui rassurante en cours at-on
cours à l'université laval a assurément
compris la bible connue que jésus lui
que j'y suis relevé m voyons je mette à
prétention je convaincu que c'est ça je
trouve ça génial et jean les artisans du
film mais c'est ça mais ça c'est
interprété ça se passe dans n'importe
quoi le même temps tu lis tu peut même
lire un article de journal en ce moment
peut l'interpréter
selon ce que toi tu veux que ça c'est
une file tout et tout et les bras
l'interprétation
moi j'ai passé mes relations amoureuses
n'importe comblant comme je sais ça mais
ça c'est un énorme problème de
communication a dit jeter qui est appuyé
mais pauvre à marssac aboutir mais je
suis maintenant mais c'est ce justement
pour revenir là à la bible et à la
religion catholique
alors il est temps qu'ils aiment c'est
ce jeu qui a fait leur succès titrait
les gens là c'était tellement flou c'est
tellement contradictoires qui décrit la
daps tellement je mets ta forêt que
chacun y trouve qu'il joue une autre
hypothèse pourquoi c'est si populaire
cette religion la première religion dans
l'espoir de magnetic s'adresse au peuple
dans toutes les autres questions avant
cette religion qui est très très très
bourgeoise les dieux étaient des
bourgeois qui faisaient ce qu'ils
voulaient avant c'était des gens très
très très puissant qui passent leurs
journées à manger des raisons peu à
boire du vin sont fâchés fort
tremblement terre
pitau qu aucun impact là dessus la
religion chrétienne c'est la première
c'est une religion qui s'intéressent au
peuple sur les gens qu'il dit s'il te
plaît faites attention à l'autre lot
d'autres attention à toi ça prend une
religion qui s'adressent ces nouvelles
jantes ou kaki et inclusive tout le
monde peut être chrétien c'est un disque
et mettons le judaïsme est simple et lui
téter et lui ont été posées l'une des
dernières nouvelles la dass et qui veut
leur doctrine et personne contrairement
à l'islam et le christianisme que jamais
un joueur qu'il faut cogner chili
abramoff c'est sa réponse
tout le monde sait que tout le monde
peut avoir la force tout le monde pas
voir la fin et j'ai reçu le plus beau
commentaire à entrer dans les vidéos et
l'autre jour ya quelqu'un qui m'a dit
dom c'est obi wan kenobi coup oui
absolument être compris montrent ce que
je vais te demande et puis je charrie
pas parlé avant le podcast parce que je
veux avoir ta dans sa réponse à froid
c'est quoi mettons un shower à froid ok
c'est qu'en mettant tata tt3 moment
cinéma qui ont qui ont marqué thomas
lebas comme c'est une excellente
question
aux premiers moments cinéma sa saison
j'avais déjà pensé à temps par les a
tant parlé tout seul chez l'enfant
unique qui est une balle des mains qui
porte sur nous tout seul tu te fais pour
jour tomates aux premiers moments cinéma
c'est sûr que c'est quand je regardais
lorsque j'ai regardé font montre jack
est allongé ses droits en avance je
crois que le cinéma c'était bien sa
place côté c'était moi c'est tous les
films que je voyais les films de steven
seagal
pour moi le cinéma c'est un gosse ça
sert à rien de plâtre là dedans ce n'est
pas qu'un simple cuisinier mais c est
pire
au niveau intellectuel samba fall métro
jacket sa première fois que ça déclic
est à tu peux dire quelque chose dans
ton film j'ai vraiment vraiment
là-dessus
mon deuxième mort assène la scène du
staff tsooji qui draine les recrues mais
cette scène là le sergent hickman on en
avait parlé je ne mange pas c'est encore
de jean pierre chevènement mrc
on en a parlé c'est le gars qui dans ce
film finalement lui était juste un peu
juste sur le site pour conseiller
l'acteur qui dispose et faire 700 plus
y'a dit comme ça marchait peuple que
j'ai qq brees qui dit hacker vas-y mon
dit comment est comme un professeur
kubrick qui dit à son insu dp tourne t
on un rôle fait clé ici mafart seuil
drilles ligue 1 toutes ces scènes là
c'était pas scriptés c'était lui le vrai
staps hudgens qui draine les gueules
pisser ep connaître ces gens choqués les
gays l'acteur s'est claqué à un rôle de
catcheur merci ce film c'est nul mais le
gars qui jouent le soldat qui suit
politique issue à l'afrique parle pas
voilà c'est le même acteur qui joue dans
men in black
sa carrière a vraiment pas arrêté de
monter parfaite oui c'est vraiment un
acteur qui trompe sur son village et
dans plein les médecins ne se
ressemblent jamais celui qui dans men in
black celui qui joue le méchant tu sais
qui marchent m'accroche à kéké le qui
boit de l'eau a su exactement et plus
mais c'est comme marque un ajustement
qui fait le nul dans star wars lui ont
le plus ou cinéma qui respire alors le
fut plein de fois mais lui mais lui
faisais des voiceover faisait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de voix je pense qu'il
joue john madden le joker et batman
oui oui tony kart ou demain justement le
j'adorais ce cumul je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment bon ensuite la comédie aussi
drôle de mouais j'ai toujours observé
que la comédie c'était des gens qui
avaient confiance en leur sein il était
beau
c'est souvent ce à quoi j'avais accès
quand j'ai vu ou d'irlande ça me
bouleverser quelque peu confiance en lui
pendant une heure et demie fin film se
fait que peu confiance en lui tout a
vraiment touché et la proche parent de
la première fois que j'ai vu ta
réflexion comme tout le monde comme
n'importe quel jeune garçon qui voient
ce qui le filme ses pochettes plaisent
ouais le parcours typique je pense je
suis le plan le plus blasé moussy mon
avis au cinéma ça a été tarantino nous
attaquent-ils quelle belle à l'époque
après ceux tombés d'un kubrick
puis c'est tombé dans ce col si le film
est un des films qui me nothing qui m'a
extrêmement marqué ces taxis quand j'ai
vu texte m'a vraiment touché vous le
verrez ce qu'ils étaient touchés en
titre et surtout un effet mix et on
parle de public
la plupart des films de strauss qui sont
extrêmement catholique croyant lui
extrêmement extrêmement même fait sa
vision de la passion de jésus christ
je suis comment ça s'appelle
malheureusement ça me revient pas mais a
fait un film sur la vie de jésus puis
lui son idée c'était que jésus avait pas
un jésus douter et deuxièmement judaïté
sont à son apogée plus proche de lui
c'est pour ceux qui luttent pour qui le
traitent mieux fait à croire que le
trait et son film a été interdit pour le
vatican ce qui est génial
si le vatican très pistons film c'est
raté ça n'excuse easy un peu plus dur
que je vais pas le voir je convaincu
sombre parce que premièrement il était
exposé le réaliser au début pendant
longtemps puis c'est lui qui m'a manqué
pour d'autres projets il passé à aucun
autre
puis justement avec le film est
clairement tellement basé sur ses
propres effets mais lui je conduis moi
c'était ces deux big lebowski oui oui
c'est bon je devais de base qui ça a
tout changé pour moi j'ai fait attaquer
tabarnak si c'est bon alors c'est quoi
qui a regardé ça a été ça a été un
presque flop au box a fait ce soir là
c'est devenu l'ultime comédie culte le
skin comique en plus c'est que je suis
même d'avis que ça change des comédies
américaines
c'est le plus parce que s'il est un des
premiers films qui est extrêmement
vulgaire c'est sur 10 399 critique du
new york times que des recherches
innovantes mairie depuis ce fameux
l'économie américaine s'est déroulé tous
les films avant tu peux pas faire de
film sexuelle et bulgares vers le bas ce
qui sont des premières comme tout le
monde y est forte
ouais 700 voix des salades vagina c'est
en septembre que quatre il fait pour la
11 septembre
ah ouais c'est bon il aimait y est nous
y sommes un tailleur garde de là
à l'égard du golfe ouais on entend on
entend par l'actrice à enchaîné c'est
quand même ce goût à ce nouveau mode
d'un truc je suis pas intéressant aussi
tout ce qu'ils entendent exact c'est
tout ce qu'ils disent tout pas brad ces
lignes dans le film c'est des choses qui
lui le goal com a pas de vocabulaire
quelque chose qui a tenté mais d'où son
ami aux frères coen on parle tout le
temps de son de son tapis
une fois il a perdu il décèle une taille
de lugano chl trucs écrits par ce qu'il
dit c'est les facois ya toujours plein
de projets en même temps
ouais c'est un film que je parle anglais
d'écriture de notre film away stx et
l'eau et moi je ne sais les films
justement c'est un film qui en surface
c'est juste drôle et niaiseux mais il
est tellement d'attention détail ces
faits noté j'ai dû le voir
douze fois ci justement justement telle
espèce de dessous contexte de contexte
social que des gars du golfe avec
justement toutes ses petites préférences
l'eau du fait que lui reprend jamais
prend toujours les avec des options il
ya tellement d'attention détail qui est
plus les chaumes à l'écouté pour écouter
puis tout en rire découvrir les autres
temps forts puis moi ça fait ce avec un
autre de mes films préférés qui je pense
est comme chez elle
comment il s'appelle l'ong one le
pornographe ouais il est chez eux plus
rap il se lève et les singles extranet
il s'en va au téléphone peut il prendre
note des signes de quoi flipper il ya
des signer un gain est restée renommage
ou de films de détective et non sur nos
matches qu'ils venaient de finir de big
sleep dans le fond début de basses qui
s'est ainsi un détective de big sleep
c'est un roman de raymond chandler qui
était fédérer 80 qui est dans le vrai
personnage principal s'est jouée par une
freebox mais c'est l'histoire d'un gars
qui comme dans le big lebowski qui
s'être your meurtre dans
1 à la haute bourgeoisie los angeles une
enquête et le ski coup dans le bixi dans
le big sleep cycle enquête est super
compliqué pour eux rien qui fêtait la
suit pas compliqué croire l'intéressé
l'intrigant s'en contre fout c'est un
hommage à des mecs jouent des bijoux et
un détective privé assez bon ils vont la
toscane cube d'eau qui coule dans le
film aussi c'est que semblerait tout est
écrit toutes les hésitations mais ouais
il pas que le personnage principal
quand il parlait à john goodman pour
d'autres versions soit établi sur le
scénario de hollywood
sept ou huit auteurs d'attentats mais
fabrique mes livres acuna la preuve la
version 2 u dance est ce ta boîte à
malle sait exactement où sa femme sont
extrêmement découper des scènes tout
leur film away photoquai bien des gens
expliqué je peux c'est vrai mais vu
qu'ils produisent eux mêmes le film
pourtant perdre des jours 3 6 1 comment
avec toute l'équipe qui est là faire des
jeux on n'est pas parce que je pense
tarantino aussi de même le vraiment
précisément pratique quand tu lis les
scénarios et internationaux la
littérature c'est vraiment vraiment
écrit mme la littérature les didascalies
6 comme un roman rapidement que
d'escalier c'est très très très voici ce
qui arrive
il rentre dans la voiture mais votre
talent ne saurai quand un noir ou à
l'improvisation c'est maintenant dans
django le classique a priori coupe la
main sur le volant mais c'est nul c'est
700 heures et quand même rendu là il l'a
quand même refusé les campagnes et le
vasa caceis est coupable mais bien comme
continuer de points de service et il
alla l'espèce 2 e mail
la mer noire qui est le fait juste par
une serviette pour il s'essuie la main
sur son ca jacket rouge le lg reste map
leur et met à pleurer avec la main ici
c'est nier la bonde amant si vous êtes
acteur local à 402,10 par leur messie
laissait quand même je m'écoute pas mis
en scène dédiée ou sont des demi dieux
sa fille font ce qu'ils veulent
peut-être
moi je dis ce que je pense à demain pour
voir ce coupé la main en cuisine ce
couple là mais moi mais ça se pourrait
que ces acteurs là son village dans une
bulle de méthane coupe la moindre minute
pas de cave fouet peut-être et on
reprend disposera j'ai réussi j'ai déjà
joué mais que le temps d'un tendon
d'achille de thierry henry le laurier
joué blessé ben plus coupure à la main
ouais mais mettons à quillan pour le
coup elle a même été des acteurs qui
prennent ou qu'ils perdent de 50 lits
sur la ruine de toi tu es wasquehal fine
x-men da pour le joker cela dedication
hashtag dedication vive
c'est ma grande question pas vraiment
c'est une nécessaire de ta maigrir mais
oui ben pour son rôle moi je pense que
ça saks a renforci le personnage puis
c'est bien plus que les députés sur un
kit elles font savoir en tabarnak
mais c'est nous c'est juste régale comme
je sais ce qui pourrait est habillé en
roux dit tout le temps tous les acteurs
soient audibles qu'on s'en rende pas
qu'on me tiens ça enlèverait l'espèce de
ça amène un cachet de bleu cela au film
définitivement sa fille du roi -
l'acteur soit plus un personnage qui
disent non moi je vois vraiment ouakam
phoenix qui a maigri des acteurs comme
daniel day lewis l'est qui se
métamorphose à chaque film est propre à
conques limite il pas un métier
tellement change sa voix il change sa
personnalité ça m'impressionne
je change ma personnalité je ne suis
plus le même homme georges tin man
anglais qui jouent à bram
mais je suis joaquin phoenix
j'ai perdu 50
ok super youpi je trouve ça
impressionnant surtout quand c'est pour
faire quand c'est pour mettre sur pied
une performance comme celle de six
personnages là avec l'a3 santé cinquième
est ce que je trouve qu'ils meilleur que
heath ledger
moi je trouve que ces deux versions
complètement de style qu'il faut
vraiment bonne mais bah moi je moi je
pense pas qu'on peut se sait ça c'est un
autre affaire ces débats là le tipi tu
vas tu vas y à ce que je veux dire quand
lebron james est allé jouer à los
angeles
il ya plein de femmes de kobe bryant qui
était qui était piste qui était pas
content qu'un autre bon joueur arrive
mais c'était un vrai fan des lakers
tu devrais peut-être juste content qu'un
autre bon joueur c'est qui le meilleur
oms en crise c'est juste deux excellents
joueurs tu fais dans ce que le de
comparer les duos cup
j'en ai vraiment rien à chier c'est le
quai riquet meilleur puis de toute façon
c'est ce qu'on compare réellement une
performance younès est un film d'action
il n'est un autre c'est plus un thriller
psychologique
tu peux pas comparer ces deux
performances de parce que le personnage
c'est le mind je crois que ça rien avoir
convaincu qu'on peut tellement qu'on
peut que sa performance est teinté de
ledger dont yves ledger et jake des
grossistes et des personnages
complètement différent super le
personnage heath ledger et les
personnages de jouer à l'infini qui sont
très déprimé qu'est-ce qui se
connaissent bien des plans dans la
voiture comment il filmait dans la
voiture c'est pareil les cheveux mauves
c'est pareil que maquillage qui lui même
sur maquillage c'est pareil jack
nicholson sport maquillage et on demande
la radio actifs j'ai beaucoup de choses
qui sont pareil parce qu'elle a mené
aussi le matériel et son jockey et le
reste le joker préexistait spécial
d'être également le film d hommage aux
films qui sont ils mais c'est parce que
moi maintenant comment je le vois de
dire comparer un film d'action avec un
trailer
puisque le gic comme ça c'est comme si
on disait et c'est qu'il est le roi
arthur que tu préfères ci-dessus
démentie par tonne de holy grail ou
d'incident klinger le film d'action
n'est pas mise à mal
tu peux pas mais arrange chasse compte
et oui ok ces deux chiffres est là oui
oui je cherchais l'expression c'est la
chose à la con paris je connais des gens
qui aiment les pommes qui déteste les
oranje s'est fait rosser ce fric à ce
qu'on pense ok les deux ont fait des
jurés ce que je peux faire le changement
dans ce cas-là ça relève d'une
préférence personnelle toute référence
personnes à la politique ses préférences
personnelles l'amour c'est une
préférence perché l'impression que dans
le des bosses et quel meilleur joker
c'est pas ce qu'est le maire joker selon
toi c'est le quelques tops préféré le
plus
je pense que c'est mettons ces hits
ledger le meilleur job mais c'est vrai
que tout le temps sans en or le
président déposé une absolue en art de
dire et c'est objectivement selon les
films de kubrick sont les français non
mais il ya des choses plus graves mais
dont je préfère voir
je pense que dans l'histoire du cinéma
par orange mécanique est plus important
que nous plus important oui plus
important sélection est ce qu'on décide
lesquels joker le plus influent qu'est
ce que tu as mon autre parent qui
particule de dieu que ce qui est génial
du c est ce qu ils disent qu'ils
essaient de sites on se rappelle
l'intérêt de ton film c'est raté ce
qu'on se rappelle d'un film ce dessin
est des moments dans le film de danse
non merci
on se rappelle de plein de trucs il ya
plein de trucs dans la société
un procédé mis la culture populaire qui
viennent sur notre expression il ya des
gens qui veulent juste pour l'homme le
monde brûle et web série s qui prit en
l'occurrence qui a pris un film qui
sorti quelques années avant ne rien nous
voulons tout seul mais
tombeur et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
séquences c'est nous qu'on se rappelle
ce qu'on se rappelle de l'indre et non
pas oui on se rappelle rien d'idiot que
tout ce qu'on se rappelle du joker heath
ledger et perdu du poids
je pense que le duo que ça va mourir les
personnes qui vont perdre du poids mais
les gens voient la queen dans les
escaliers dans le bronx
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment un
commentaire sur et qui commet qu'on
traite les gens aient vraiment aux états
unis ça n'a pas de sens et seuls ses
seuls films et c'est tout à fait 6
passes qui est magique et un peu magique
qui dit yj
il se promène dans le temps c'est parce
c'est vrai on sait pas c'est pas vrai et
assassine du monde il serait jamais
panis est très très fort malade mental
génial que imed il mange pas à sa faim
mais peu de monde
nathan gunn avec ses collègues chefs
avec tim raines je sais je sais pas me
demande pas d'argent je veux place
n'étaient pas des rucks
je sais pas parce que le truc c'est que
l'homme qui souffre de maladie mentale
m'expliquer ce que les gens comprennent
pas la maladie mentale à quel point ça
paralyse souvent de familles et quand il
était malade mental et dans ce film lui
il fait plein d'action clean révolution
la part des gens dans les encadrements
toki poney révolution sur la difficulté
à sortir de leur lit le film ne
comprenait le management table basse et
même pas la maladie mentale c'est l'idée
qu'on sait de la maladie mentale exemple
aux walis litzler fous sont malades
mentaux sont vraiment eu un fou l'idée
est vraiment fou fonds souverains m'en
fous ou si les gens qui comptent qui
sont assez chance aussi à patna
que tout je sais pas ou si c'est quoi la
police et tué 36 quotas folie où c'est
tous des bonnes questions que le film ne
se pose pas le film prend juste l'idée
des belles de cnn que si tu les autres
suis fou ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
pas une discipline s'est pas vraiment
c'est parce que je déteste du film c'est
que ce sont ses maîtres de l'art mais ça
prend l'idéologie des mois j'ai
l'impression bilan de force de ce film
là c'est justement de faire ce sa force
et sa niveau c'est d'amener dans un
média mainstream en utilisant une ou des
monstres in que le joker un film de
super héros dans un monde en ce moment
où est ce que les seuls films qu'ils
sont écoutés au cinéma c'est des films
de super héros ou est-ce que tu prends
un film
ce concept le mais tu réussis par la
porte arrière a montré une critique
sociale même s'il faut que les tressois
on n'est pas en train de regarder avec
sociale
tout le monde est d'accord avec tout le
monde c'est une idée à laquelle tout le
monde est d'accord mais la série legend
il s'agit pas là et ultra pas de raison
qu'ils lutteraient pas d'argent j'ai une
idée que c'est une idée qu'on s'est fait
que les oui parce que d'un côté je
t'écoute cfm leap tu développes
l'empathie envers ses personnages le
destin soir c'est du coup si dans le
premier film à faire maintenant mais en
utilisant des codes de médium un swing
de blocs de blockbuster de box office
c'est ça la force du film j'ai
l'impression c'est d'amener dans un dans
un système avec des codes très distincts
pour amener le monde au cinéma puis la
preuve c'est que ça allait exploser le
style et le box office a été non
monsieur je voudrais milliards puis
amené ce monde-là 1 voir un film qui est
pas un film de super héros de pierre
biau de vaisseau spatial puis un film
qui fait quand même réfléchir non de
personnes sont sorties de ce film le
puits qui ont regardé les itinéraires
d'une façon différente
je sors que c'est par centaines de
milliers je pense pas en californie et
jusqu'à présent les gens ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est pas aidé les itinérants c'est
aller mais ce que je vous ai grandi se
prendre en photo dans l'escalier
ça c'est le monde que tu vois les photos
tellement cynique mais pis pour pour
répondre à ce que tu dis pas rapport
qu'elle fournit au total à san francisco
juste une soirée la piste est un
festival de sans abri le problème aussi
c'est un film sur new york le jeudi
l'espace agatha mais c'est new york
mais c'est aussi c'est aussi ça la rend
aussi partout se met maintenant mais
c'est moi je trouve pas que suscite le
monde d'accord avec se trouve qu'au
contraire c'est un film qui en a qui
vont qui critiquent fortement parce
qu'ils disent a fait l'apologie des
tueurs puis de 10 puis ça prend la
défense je m'en réjouis car dans les
écoles qui dessus ou qui rentre au
cinéma bis qui tuent les gens
de l'autre côté c'est un film qui
justement qui qui expose voici en un
problème il ya des gens qui sont
atteints de tir malade mental qui sont
sani cup comme du monde ça peut mais ça
s'est tellement américain
il faut s'occuper de monstres ils vont
tuer les sparnaciens c'est super
américains comme réflexion de fo aider
les pauvres que peut-être que les
pauvres vont nous voler c'est l'idée du
film ceci on est on est méchant que les
pauvres les pauvres se venge d'encre et
ça marche parce que votre ferme à
l'autre ça fait c'était beaucoup plus
forte
faut juste céder quand tu peux aider
quelqu'un fait le tout aidé quelqu'un
parce que tout parent qui te frappe une
d'extrême américaine
la phase de test faiblesse des valeurs
derrière ce film là qui sont extrêmement
bizarre qui sont extrêmement violentes
sadi même livre et le film se dit les
pauvres sont vielles ça à la fin tous
les ports se mettent ensemble se mettre
des masques pour une révolution
ça arrive pas ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on observe par contre ça arrive c'est
arrivé dans l'histoire ça arrive c'est
souvent les révolutions c'est la
bourgeoisie avait souvent la révolte et
les révolutions on regarde la révolution
française c'est plus la bourgeoisie que
pris la place des rois
les révolutions dans le moyen-orient tu
n'es pas joué de chance en ce moment je
peux rien devant la soie la révolution
s'est déroulée au milieu des coûts mills
et des coups d'état militaires c'est le
peuple voit dans la rue et leurs larmes
effet comme une onde est un gros prendre
la place c'est ce qui se produit
c'est ce qui s'est passé est une
révolution puis l'armée a pris le
pouvoir
voilà bien d'après pouvoir me laver mais
l'armée n'a pas fait tout seul c'est le
pense que les gens que je connais
puisque la personne qui fait ce qu'on
voudrait ainsi que le caporal prennent
le pouvoir pense pas c'est toi
ces films là c'est un peu il ya aussi un
autre truc c'est ce que le gagner il
faut un pastiche de taxi driver c'est
moins 40 ans il arrive qu il yad autres
films sont cités les fils de network de
beaucoup d'autres films qui sont
référencés comprendre un des films taxi
mais ils posent pas la réflexion
quarante ans plus tard il pousse pas la
réflexion
une fois sa finale à memphis quand cela
prend une tournée bull est meilleure
soit pas le choix quand on reprend une
chanson
cela mène à un haut niveau devrait même
leur être quand écoute la chanson
précédente à ses moins bons c'est seul
objectif je pense pas que ces gens
censés apprendre qu'une fois par la rend
touchant c'est intéressant ce film là
car il ya eu 40 ans pour réfléchir en
temps pendant lesquelles des films comme
ce sont pour regarder mais je reviens
sur je reviens je reviens au fait que ça
ça fait que du monde qui s'attendaient à
les voir un film de super héros qui ont
vu un film qu'il aura fait réfléchir
mais on me suis vraiment réfléchi
wissant pour ça ça ça répète des codes
et des idées qui avait déjà je fasse
attention
les pauvres ont fait mal c'est parce
qu'il est difficile et pau font mal la
fin la fin du film tu aimes le grillé
boeuf fait mal au monde
non mais tout le film senghor détresse
qui essaie d'aborder l'aide de paul je
pense que c'est jusqu'à temps que ça
explose 02 au deux tiers des fermes et
ou le touch famille et s'essayer comme
abandonnée par le système
c'est ce que c'est ce que tu ressens tu
sais ce que c'est ça que je percevais
ses 7 aces par set investi pour se jeter
touché puis pape est intéressant à
l'inversé que le système qu'est-ce que
ça monte c'est que ce système abandonne
dégageant les gens pensent
je pense que la fin de ce film là c'est
plus un clin d'oeil à l'univers du duo
que que quoi que ce soit d'autre
si je pense que c'est plus je pense que
la fin de ce film c'est plus de dire
puis by the way c'est la genèse de la
personne qui vous connaissez et puis de
l'histoire dans laquelle on le retrouve
dans batman s'effacer pas de membres et
des fans si c'est ça que j'ai
l'impression que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont fait la clé le clin d'oeil de
comme tout le monde a des masques vie
c'est ça ou un peu la porte où est ce
qu'on le retrouvait plus tard dans
l'histoire de marvel mais j'ai vraiment
pas l'impression que c'est ça le point
du film vraiment pas là j'ai
l'impression que ça c'est juste un un
esprit comme quelqu'un qui veut voir
bruce wayne c'est juste un espèce de
petit bonbon monde qui sont allés juste
pour son appui puis j'ai l'impression
que cette espèce de 15 minutes afin
qu'ils aient plus de l'ordre du film de
super héros devrait pas discréditer le
1h45 et oublie tout tout tout tout tout
seul et à la fin oui le but tout le
début ce pour la fin c'était surprenant
c'est ça c'est justement parce je pense
pas que le film est un leader parce que
je pense que le film en tant que tel
mais tant que tu prends l'avait le
premier une heure et demie je pense que
c'est vraiment fait pour faire la
critique du traitement qu'on qu'on fait
en tant que société des maladies
mentales
puis elle a su le dernier 15 minutes
parce que là tout explose bleus issus de
niro pelé bresson et de la révolution
dans rupture je pense c'est vraiment
juste pour les peaux mais selon nos
attentes de marques dans l'univers
marvel tu mets ça discrédite paul firme
si ça ne se passe pas une scène qui est
un pote discrédité dans le film au congo
la scène c'est l'acte final
ouais c'est pas une stricte pour une
scène en plein milieu séquence en
séquence d'événements haut responsable
c'est la fin tous à menacer tout le film
s'écroule si tout le budget avec ça je
sais que tu peux lire un livre qui est
vraiment la bombe puis si le dernier
chapitre c'est de la merde
le livre ça reste la bombe non pour ce
que la fin tu ne t'es jamais écoutés
du jamais vu maintenant quand t'écoutes
une gamme de basque une gaine basket je
lui crie parce qu'ici la fin c'est de la
merde ça discrédite la game au complet
c'est différent le sport est une oeuvre
d'art que je réfléchisse parce que le
sport si tu vas voir un spectacle piqué
le rappelle c'est de la merde c'est très
agréable
c'est très grave pour rappel sur carton
encore l'aspect spectacle rappelle ses
premières oeuvres non mais ils les et
lettonie sont planifiées des jeux et ça
reste qu'ils vont jouer je pense pas que
m concert c'est une suite de chansons
n'est pas obligé si tu écoutes un album
puis que la dernière tourne c'est de la
merde ça discrédite l'album noter pour
l'hygiène album de faire ça au complet
une histoire le beau gerard t'étais pas
là quand c'est le but d'une histoire
c'est la fin non histoire nom d'un film
début d'une histoire si tu construis un
truc et la fin que je pense que par la
fin tu veux dire là la conclusion bâti
les flamands le message du film vraiment
le moral ou à quoi que ce soit du film
pour sa conclusion georges par la fin le
dernier est également le fils ben oui le
plus important c'est la fête je
construit toute ton histoire c'est pour
la fin je pense que je peux raconter
matches pointe
oui matches pointe la fin est
extraordinaire de la faim est
exceptionnel avec l'anneau qui tombe
d'un côté de l'autre
c'est le dernier plan mais la fin c'est
le but de match point tout le long du
film et explique serais tu prêt à faire
des murs pour qu'est-ce que tu
préfèrerais avoir une relation amoureuse
ou dans quel type aux biens ou tueur est
donc conforme ou moins de confort
migration and rush que tu aimes et la
fin la fin mai tout le film est de faire
croire qu'il va aller vers vivre l'amour
fort que le confort dit non ou enfin
faire fort que la mort vive le confort
la fête extraordinaire
le dernier plan ça ce n'est qu'une fable
métaphore mais la feinte exceptionnelle
sur le but du film s'arrêter plati tout
le film il dit à la presse
l'important c'est l'amour la fin c'est
l'important c'est l'amour qu'elle fait
m'ennuyant j'ai vraiment été voir un
fait milliards gogh m'expliquer que la
mort est plus fort que tout ou h
mais ce qu'il fonde fims quito
tous l'ont été mais là quelque part
pittman ailleurs seul le but de
construire un film s'est construit
quelque chose des petites tombes n'était
pas d'accord à ce que fait mme dispute a
pas aimé ça ne s'était pas encore que le
film dit vraiment pas je pourrais encore
une interprétation et peut-être
l'axé biaisé parce qu'on est tous bien
c'est peut-être dans l'adaptation mais
peut-être qu'il y en a d'autres à voir
aussi que c'est aussi légitime le trou
béant au dessus tout est perçu quelque
chose d perçu comme mais vous des fous
ce nom on veut totalement on y voit
justement
ok c'est ce que j'ai observé à la fin tu
es tout le monde sait pas vraiment mais
c'est vraiment ça alors ils prennent le
temps de faire des longs plans au
ralenti ou un pauvre qui très riche mais
mais ces soldats qui m'ont il ya deux et
les familles a family wayne sont super
riches
il sort du cinéma avec les pauvres il
sort de leur palace pour aller avec la
population ils descendent de leur
montagne arrive à la population ils se
font tuer par un pauvre seul film mais
tous les temps le jeune femme sait que
le joker responsables de la mort des
parents a besoin c'est ça le film c'est
le film c'est la france fut oui tout se
construisent tout toutes et tous les
éléments sa menace
ben oui mais c'est sûr il ya clairement
une critique des classes mais d'une
bourgeoisie déconnecté on peut je
croyais pas ce que c'est attention je
vais lui font mal à personne je parlais
par contre je pense que c'est un peu un
jour de plus je pense que se pose pas
c'est un peu un voici ce qui se passe de
société ou est-ce que les classes se
méprisent six communes y parle pas par
contre d'autres un peu comme dans un
film que tu as beaucoup mx appels
parasites ma faim qui gagne qui gagnent
les parasites les riches gagnent le but
parasite le but à la conclusion de
parasites c'est que toute la richesse
des pauvres dépend toute la richesse des
riches dépend du travail des pauvres et
que les riches de manière
que littéraire dans la bride les régions
sud et sont aptes dessus les pauvres
libres sont littéralement sont dans les
excréments
c'est le but est que les régions restées
riches et que les pauvres restent
pauvres et malheureusement le but de
parasites ce n'est pas le cas il y en
aura pas de changement que l'on social
ce n'est pas pour mourir pauvre et si tu
n'est riche trop riche que ça existe ça
existe pochon les classes sociales
ils ont essayé les pauvres gens près dé
capable c'est ça le but de parasites
c'est des pauvres que les riches sont
regardables couple intéressant mais mais
je trouve que c'est un film qui dit
parce que tous les personnages
principaux sont pauvres de reflets pis
mais moi je trouve que c'est un film qui
dit on est tous les parasites de
quelqu'un parce que cette femme il a
deux pauvres méprise complètement la
famille de riches qui dans le chic y
travaillent et vice versa désosser si
riche le méprise les riches et les clés
pis ces pauvres le con qu'on suit la
famille principal le soul on dans la rue
qui arrivent et qui pèse partout et où
tous leurs parasites parce qu'il tente
sous d autres enfin que tout le monde et
est classé stratégie comme comme un
disque comme des sociétés vraiment les
parasites des pauvres riches oui
absolument
parisé déportés lyrisme et c'est aussi
le plus pauvre c'est une ville d or et
des récentes quelques heures c'est
brillant comme idée et on est tous très
soudés quelqu'un brillance et réagit le
joker mais cela ne peut pas faire ça
pour que ce soit vu je suis d'accord
avec toi qui est le joker c'est pas le
meilleur film que j'ai vu de ma vie le
ballon il meilleur fait ce que j'ai vu
c'est un faux pas en considération
politique moi je sois belle est il faut
prendre en considération le monde
fournit existants nuit énormément mais
il faut considérer la porte et la portée
exacte faut que tu mets ton là c'est sûr
que un film qui fait fait un en italie
vu par gep à 15000 personnes qui ultra
neige mais qui est insensé de critique
va être vu par plus que 15 des personnes
mais qui encensent et des critiques en
repos la même portée va pas se permettre
d'être pas mal plus edgy qu'un film qui
étudie à qui le je veux essayer d'amener
le monde au cinéma c'est pas même les
radiateurs de parasites ira en corée du
sud sur le store voilà il fait des films
populaires du cinéma mais c'est un peu
débile qui ont accepté qu'on états unis
le cinéma palace à tout ce qu'on dit ça
on dit on parle du cinéma la télévision
américaine extrêmement nuancé et puis
l'extrême les séries américaines sont
réputés pour être nuancée réfléchi pour
déi pour des adultes un public adulte
c'est super populaire samedi raison
pourquoi mon avis décidément commence à
perdre de l'ale alors si je pense que ça
vient de mourir s'ils pensent comme ceux
ci fait bien là pour que mon arrêt au
cinéma pour faire des films où le monde
du spectacle mais ça s'est passé avec la
demande saas et fatah demande de dire le
monde ont commencé à aller voir ces
films là parce que c'était ceux qui
voulaient aller voir sur des écrans
géants
nous on oublie aussi que dans la demande
beaucoup du booker dans les budgets des
films en vo n'est raison qu on y vote
ans et qui met tellement d'argent qu'on
a et le voir c'est pas juste le marché
car c'est aussi l'appui style mais
maintenant si je suis pour amener ma
femme est au cinéma ça va coûter 100
piasses pour une sortie au cinéma ça va
être pour un film qui vaut la peine
d'être vu surgir en géant avec des
bordures trompeur du marché le marché
des signes que ça coûte 100 pièces
obligé de mettre 60 pièces ce marché
existe et ça la marche ici c'est aussi
ça s'est décidé au procès mills à
contacter les familles
jacou 200 dollars machinalement ce
mondial est je pense que je sais pas si
c'est une question que moins de noms qui
vont bien moi je suis persuadé j'ai
persuadé qu'il ya beaucoup moins de
monde qui vont au cinéma maintenant que
des années soixante dix ça c'est sûr et
certain c'était moins cher fait que plus
on tue pour se permettre la moindre
alternative mais plutôt de faire chez
nous je peux suivre mais n'importe quel
film qui soit sorti une entité pis si
c'est un film qui vaut pas la peine
d'être vu sur écran géant
tu peux être certain que je peux pas me
déplacer au cinéplex à côté de chez nous
par les lecteurs c'est sûr que non
maintenant tous les films pour que les
effets spéciaux et non mais c'est ça la
force du joker c'est qu'il n'a pas de
chance je fais un petit coup de charme
et c'est ça doit pas coûter aussi cher
qu'un film comme thème qui me soucier
spéciaux pour exact film qui taxera
facebook dont les facultés un film
avengers enlève des éditions si bon si
nous la merde il reste plus rien ce
c'est possible c'est ça la force aussi
mettant du coup leur [ __ ] sachiez après
puis que manger moins mais ce que c'est
entendu il y en a pas d'effets spéciaux
il y en a mais il ne faudrait un peu de
galon yann on les trouve la première
trilogie qui ont fait des jeunes effets
spéciaux et justement non c# à cause de
ce prix spéciaux c'est cher parce qu'ils
sont en des shots de crime dans une
forêt des chocs de 15 secondes coûte un
million à tourner non mais c'est ce que
c'est bourru des vestiges en a plein
mais je pense qu est ce que tu veux dire
c'est que c'est ça l'effet spécial qui
fait qu'il y en ait pu même que c'est le
fait qu'un homme - marcheurs à marcq -
arrêtons les chaudes et le capteur en
nouvelle-zélande du green screen
ouais c'est au tricot en nouvelle
zélande d'un paysage laboy sont déplacés
pour ce que ça coûte extrêmement cher
mais c'est ce qui fait que s'est fixée
la tue moi c'est pour ça que je trouve
que le joker bref au circle joker pour
ceux qui trouvent ça ça l'a réussi dans
ce que ça voulait faire ça doit faire un
film qui est pas basé sur des explosions
puis du cidj hype du green screen que le
monde vont aller au cinéma pour voir qui
sont déplacés massivement pour aller
voir un film comme on faisait trente ans
c'est dur que dans le fond laisse la
plus grande arnaque daily star disney
was his past appelle son joker et batman
est foncièrement ok mais il aurait pu
s'appeler double au mois de mai c'est
réussi
au lieu d'appeler à gotham tablette à
new york où brûlent d'appeler ce wend
appelle ceux ci donnent à nos noms qui
est un film pareil puis personnes voient
le lien avec la demande comment tu le
temps mais tant que c'est un film de
batman mais le syngof avis à chaud
sourit des ports batman c'est une idée
extrêmement de droite conservatrice
batman c'est l'histoire d'un
milliardaire qui te justifier qu'il va
battre des pauvres c'est ce l'idée de
batman
le film de joe gatti fin c'est la mitis
et d'idéologie de batman c'est pour ça
que c'est nul je te quand les effets
mais là c'est un film - avec une
idéologie blizzard fait pas terrible
c'est un gars extrêmement riche qui a
fait un nom veut il est extrêmement
riche qu est-ce qui connaît à la
pauvreté vivent à new york
c'était un gars qui vit dans un palace à
beverly hills qui connaît non mais je
vais le messager c'est un sophisme 12
mai s'explique pour garder le message is
est important ce que je voulais dire à
tous et pour marquer que depuis dans les
premiers films c'est un truc que tu
m'enlèves servi dans les premiers films
star wars quand george lucas était rien
la force tout le monde l'avait
l'intérieur de soi c'est solide et la
force si tu vaux avons au fond de toi tu
peux être héros quand jean-luc est
devenu milliardaire danse à dos aux
nôtres il agit la force était dans le
sens non oui c'est clair que le messager
chance et que dans villes hôtes une
perspective de la société tellement
différentes caisses quand on cite 20
pièces d'un compte chèque ou vingt ou
vingt millions tout change tout change
c'est extrêmement conservateur comité
c'est tellement conservateur lee joker
c'est fait par des gens qu'est ce que
c'est con ça va tu sais susciterait mais
étrangement je ne peux pas le background
que oui alors mais qui sait aussi
prendre le wagon de rédacteur pour
encenser un film mettant le background
tarantino c'est que vu tous les films
c'est quoi sont ces films cd hommage au
cinéma c'est une relecture du cinéma
c'est important de prendre en
considération
je pense poubelle non moi je regarde le
guen doivent à terme jugent leur pascal
et tout c'est super important d'avoir
d'où vient l'artis kafka et kafka avec
ce qu'ils véhiculent peut-être causé
lundi quand tu connais la relation entre
kafka et son père surtout s'explique on
met tous explique moi mais ça sans
arrière ta compréhension sont à saïda
est tellement side cela ne faut pas faut
pas que la provenance de l'artiste
deviennent clés de compréhension c'est à
mon avis une clé jeudi super bon on en a
parlé obsédé par la guerre mondiale mais
moi si calais si j'étais juif puis y
avait d'ailleurs une guerre mondiale où
déjà ouvertement voulait as voulu me
tuer pour mon ethnie obsédé par ça c'est
normal qu'à l'aller le schindler au
début les déchets de la régie ce fait
par un juif c'est fait c'est un projet
qui durerait des années parce qu'ils
voulaient donner plein de radiateur qui
ne des petits n'étaient pas juifs
système était mal reste non pensez vous
qu'il y ait de chine là ça serait aussi
touchée si c'était fait en italie 100 %
pensent pas le film quand elle sera
aussi touchant c'est sur le même score 6
jeudi je veux produire squeeze wulff a
bien fait mais non c'est ton histoire
c'est bien mieux mieux raconter parce
qu'à cause son background mais rendu là
on s'en fout je pense pas je pense que
la présence d'artistes et fils c'est
tellement important
je pense qu'une oeuvre c est forte les
autos prêtre avait quand même depuis que
depuis que des femmes qui font du cinéma
là les femmes au cinéma sont beaucoup
les personnages de femmes sont beaucoup
plus intéressants mais oui mais je sais
pas évidemment mais évidemment c'est
vrai pour tous
c'est vrai pour absolument c'est vrai
pour disparaître depuis que des noirs
qui réalise des films ben comment les
noirs son cursus il aimait beaucoup plus
été le seul finalement c'est évidemment
mais ça changera pas écrit ça change
rien caen est de savoir le background
une fois ça c'est un fait que évidemment
que plus une réalisatrice femmes + leaf
en moins de mises de l'avant c'est
parfait mais sache
blaireau devant moindre espace qui est
parce qu elle parce que la canette de
coca par évidemment sauf que si près la
même offre la même oeuvre le même film
la même chose une un personnage féminin
fort bien la présenter a précisé qu'il
le fait ça change tout moi je crois que
qui fait quelque chose ça change tout
ben c'est sûr que c'est sûr que
l'artiste y est pour beaucoup dans le
succès de son oeuvre mais une fois que
comme 2010 une fois club et terminer ça
appartient à ryad en s'imposant une fois
que le werder ça appartient plus à
l'artiste on s'en fout bon sens tout
petit intéressé après avoir vu quelque
chose peut t'intéresser farah kg en
reste avant de cliquer compréhension peu
apprécié voir que spielberg lui il
traite de la deuxième guerre mondiale je
peux faire sur mais une fois que leur
ville à une fois que le livre existe on
s'en fout tu l'écris non j'ai passé
facilement savoir qui le fait c'est pour
ça que fascinant c'est intéressant
intéressant puis ça donne beaucoup de
qualités besoin d'avoir plus de clés
mais une fois que mais l'offre qui
existe
je pense qu'elle est voudrait avoir
toutes les clés en même lève c'est est
incapable de ressortir l'essence de
l'oeuvre sans l'ailier snowhall y
rajoute des biographies
c'est la vie des gens qui quittent
intéressante je pense que l'oeuvre doit
avoir tout ce qui a besoin
intrinsèquement un brillant d'elle pour
avoir besoin d'aller chercher plus loin
ce soir c'est réussi mais on veut pas
des chefs-d'oeuvre tout le temps non
c'est je crois que c'est essentiel
savoir d'où les personnes liées ça
change tout ça c'est que tata
perspective c'est important voir un film
qui me dérange pas qu'il faut mais au
contraire sa clique pas fait étrange
s'intéresse aux gens qui font le film
sera voilà c'est mettons les 9 meilleurs
big lebowski des frères coen sont
obsédés par la philosophie quand c'est
intéressant frequenza les grisons
observable à la philosophie
fa oui mais c'est pas c'est le film pas
meilleure examinons effet que je peux
voir ça comme étant le maître de ses
fils mais tout ça fait que m 2 oui on a
besoin de sa fille
c'est un peu un staff c'est un peu une
manière que les éléphants qui ont montré
ce faible hausse est encore plus riches
quand il regarde une autre fois c'est
encore plus phone 7 phone pour revoir le
film
jeudi soir m le dis toi même ce qui le
fonde the big lebowski c'est qu'il ya
tellement de couches que quand tu le
regardes une autre fois c'est
intéressant
la personne qui fait l'oeuvre m je les
fais toujours le lire sur lire sur les
thèmes que je viens de voir qu'ils
défendent leurs avoirs en lumière de ce
livre des analyses ou non vient de paix
global ce qui les fait toutes les frères
coen ces 2 god du ministre
2/2 aux textes qui vont qui sont soit
installé à los angeles avec le bal ce
qui on peut voir que c'est un peu comme
les frères coen ces dégâts étranger à la
haute bourgeoisie du de la santé restent
sur plus de bugs le basque ces trois
gars qui vont dans la haute bourgeoisie
de l'injs puis il rencontre un pont en
gaf bizarre il rencontre un millionnaire
qui réalise qu'ils pourront millionnaire
a juste l'argent d'un autre il son
panier avec plein de trucs étranges
l'intégration est ce que tu as dit
tantôt 56e puis évidemment ça vaut la
peine de réfléchir sur neuf d'aller lire
d'autres analyses pour la comprendre
mieux ça qui fait l'oeuvre
ouais ou qui fait l'oeuvre c'est sûr ça
ça à pédales voir d'un autre oeil ou de
voir des choses que tu voyais pas mais
si tu vois le revoir après ça c'est
parce que c'est dans l'oeuvre pas cillé
le nom et qui dit l'artiste le transmis
dans son oeuvre
oui si l'artiste est intéressant mais
transmet rien à ses heures 6 heures sont
pas intéressantes que je pourrais avoir
dû prévoir la ville la plus intéressante
je prends véhicule est la plus grande
chose si je transmets passe en 2009 mais
est quand même pas bonne ok c'est pas le
meilleur parce que moi j'ai une vie
trépidante mais en croix d'or que ces
indiens l'artiste s'est préparée par un
point important est important d'où vient
l'artiste qui est l'artiste fait cela
ben oui moi je crée mes récents c'est
primordial
c'est vraiment vraiment intéressant
savoir d'où vient l'artiste c'est super
intéressant je suis d'accord avec toi
que c'est vraiment intéressant on est
vraiment diar devrait peau
juger une oeuvre par qui et son artiste
jugé laurent reçoit devrait elle pas de
la nascar à cause de cet arrondissement
qui le réalisera au registre est ce que
fait mais bon pied bon parce que c'est
tarantino qui le réaliser ou parce que
si untel ou untel on dérape et d'aller
le prix à cause que c'est lui au départ
les prix thomas vous aimeraient qu'on
change je suis pas ce qu'elle est on a
parlé beaucoup ta passion pour le cinéma
oui mais une autre passion que je sais
qu'ils aient quitté très cher est
importante c'est la sexualité la donne
ces gars que je connais qui aiment le
plus qui parle plus des ex que j'avais
rencontré que j'aime sur une activité
que j'adore vraiment pas de gars 1 pour
moi l'été sexologue
voilà moi je me tais j'ai été élevé par
un gars qui est utilisé à sectionner
j'attends quand même pas les 500
amateurs de temps et on jamais la même
et mon père étaient sexologue on parlait
jamais texture est à la maison ses
claques sa mort qui tue voulais
comprendre souffler oui par contre
j'étais j'ai eu accès à la sexualité de
montage du sous entendu parler mon père
c'est fascinant quand 6 à 10 ans
je peux parler ma sexualité sans trop
être vulgaire parce que je sais c'est
quoi des gens qui rentrent dans la bulle
de l'autre c'est tellement important
savoir d'où viendra je suis fasciné par
la sexualité tant de temps par un call
of satan n'étant pas passer alors j'ai 8
ans de 8 à l'âge de 16 ans j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup trop de mon père faire
l'amour très fort pourquoi tata venture
qui était proche de la sienne non mais
vraiment très fort ok c'est encore plus
depuis que d'un bruyant s'était passé
partenaires de ses personnages les deux
les deux départs les pat wright est très
bruyante et lui aussi plusieurs
batailles oui parce que mon père ma mère
est morte quand j'avais l'âge de 4 ans
beaucoup de blanc s'est montré très très
tôt dans ma vie j'ai vu mon père auprès
de rapport sexuel des femmes différentes
puis le set je pense que cette héroïne
convaincu vaincu convaincu qu'on est qu
on voudrait pas un enfant ne va pas être
aussi conscient de la sexualité balle en
jeu qu'on vécu
l'humain qui était sexologue il va pas
non où il pensait port ça chez moi
sexuelle j aimerais mon père est très
très très exceptionnelle surtout quand
on se voit que tu penses que c'est une
bonne des deux fours extrêmement fort
quand un enfant de 8 ans dans la gaude
et lui crois que c'est l'une des
cuisines est convaincu ou peut-être que
peut-être que pour avoir une sexualité
accompli ça prenait le bruit puis que ça
allait au delà de police test est plus
important d'aller chez les priorités je
suis d'accord analyse
d'accord à noter déjà ne parlait jamais
j'aime mélanger matin quand les vélos
déjà népal et géophysiques comment
aborder et qu'on perd quand tu fais
l'amour s'est réjoui il est large dose
et je ne sais pas comment gérer ça j'ai
jamais eu cette conversation
jamais jamais jamais t4 la moto est
brillant non je silencieux la raison
pourquoi je fais si peu de bruit c'est
que j'adore la sexualité et je suis
d'avis qu'il faut parler de masturbation
est le plus le plus tôt possible et
encourager les gens se masturber que les
gens qui se masturbe sont beaucoup plus
détendue les gens qui se massent 3 mai
limitant soit à l'installation
non non non il est pas de limites alma
se passe pas un peu trop ce masters je
danse pour que je pense pas qu'on peut
tôt ce matin non mais ça a amené le
danger c'est la masturbation avec la
biographie pourquoi parce que
éventuellement la limite on en fait la
frontière entre la pornographie ta vie
sexuelle va devenir de plus en plus
floue puis moi je suis d'avis qu'il faut
travailler aussi son imaginaire dans la
masturbation
j'ai l'impression qu'il faut une bonne
balance maintenant quand j'ai pas
beaucoup de temps à perdre
j'utilise la pornographie puis quand
j'ai plus de temps pas perdre ne
mélangez pas perdu on le cas j'ai plus
de temps je fais l'exercice mental je
trouve que c'est être capable de
reproduire des trucs qui sont plus
proches de ma vraie sexualité
avec ma tête quand je regarde adrian
chez c'est probable ça m'amuse toujours
cet argument là que la pornographie
c'est beau comme la vraie sexualité mais
tant que c'est pas je suis d'accord avec
toi cet accord avec toi par contre si tu
une fake consommer ça quand tu procure
un plaisir j'imagine qu'ils y voient une
espèce de réponse de pavlov qui vote qui
va faire que si la fée l'a22 bros
complet dans le truck culte ou laisser
la mairie c'était cette rixe pôle
jeunesse 5 4 il y en a plusieurs
pour l'argent je connais comme ça des
deux gros sacs à dos au banc d'essai que
soit fait commencé en 2001 christian
cadiot l'aquila non mais là c'est parce
que j'ai définitivement exagéré mais et
moi je regardais affaire je n'ai jamais
dans ma sexualité à moi je vais
augmenter genre la fille qui jouait web
qu'est ce que tu vas chercher en
polygraphie qui virent jamais notre
sexualité
lucile fond tu peux le faire je peux
physiquement moralement le faire fait
que les grands noms mais mendy genre
chez polti trois filles qui se sent
pénis qui se les rend tellement loin
dans la gauche qu'il ya un plan qui sont
rouges ça leur fera par année je préfère
ça finit par faire
est ce que je fais je peux le regarder
mais ça arrivait dans mon intimité à moi
avec quelqu'un qui est proche de moi
puis qu'il a semé d'affaires ce qui a
pleuré tellement qu'il a dites chaudes
je sais pas si j'aimerais ça est-ce que
ça teksid quand tu le regardes dont on
écrit ben qu'oui parfois alors pourquoi
si j'essayais non je t'encourage à face
2020 un exemple exact c'est pas vraiment
ou qui décide
comme c'est pas comme ça ici non
comment quelqu'un qui a sculpté petit
pleure ça existe des gens qui déjà
autant que ça existe de voir l'autre
personne pluri et des gens qui ça les
excite tellement avons répété ce creux
qui pleure ça existe c'est 2 ces deux
personnes ne pas se trouver mais oui
mais ce qui est ce qui est tout à fait
là son amoureuse non c'est moi c'est
drôle parce qu'on est vieux gag pas
voilà ça me rend non mais non médecins
vif des fantasmes c'est fini je pense à
4 heures ou jusqu'à ce mois se passe
quand même je comprends qu est-ce que
cette enquête on peut aller le tigre
sauf que je veux pas la sexualité la
pornographie est quand même souvent loin
de la sexualité de tous les jours des
québécois moyen en fait non il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de sexualité c'est
juste deux personnes qui prennent leur
iphone qui bâille beaucoup de bien de
points c'est même très très proche de 6
c'est ce qui à mon avis très dommage la
pornographie en ce moment ce que devient
extrêmement normal adverse en bout c'est
juste des gens qui sont avec leur
cellulaire
c'est très très amateur dans notre
exemple par exemple exemple je regarde
la vidéo hockey où il ya eu 8 go chacun
leur tour vienne sa phase d'une fille 8
go oui le sexe en groupe sans beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'extraits oui je
risque mais il ya moyen de faire l'amour
en gros plat c'est faisable mais c'était
super bourgault qu'une plateforme you
moyens les gens me plaît dans les
commentaires
mettez vous un gag les filles qui va
dormir bon cette semaine avec la
boutique toll qui provoque pas mal de là
j'ai pas mal de théâtre mais est-ce que
j'ai le goût c'est cette question j'ai
pas le serment le goût d'y réaliser ce
que j'aimerais être l'un de ses 8 go là
je regarde la scène mais magie dans la
seine schiele il ya cette autre godec
moi on se touche un peu yann m'vila
milieu qui j'étais vraiment le goût de
la 30e et de gueule je pense pas je
pense pas que j'ai laissée sur ma
sexualité comme site mais quand tu le
regardes ton élection samedi
c'est que vous je pense pas génial bien
tu regardes la pornographie ni que tu
dis mais j'ai pas le goût est là où tout
le monde ment kergall apprenait
graphique il ya concordance avec la
sexualité non mais boisé qui en fait oui
oh oui généralement te regarde sinon une
bande bon quand je regarde deux gosses
[ __ ] je ne boude pas parce que ça n'a
pas rapport consultée ouais mais toi si
des textiles moi j'ai envie de voir et
de le prendre une fille la fille a pas
d'issue un excellent je sais pas si
moi-même moi même acheter et qui mollit
dès le 2 août avec une façon très
différente parce que c'est que j'étais
parti oui mais continue ok ok c'est moi
et c'est quoi ton molybdène et le dr
mettons une soirée tout avec une fille
que j'apprécie vraiment beaucoup on veut
manger de quoi on va au cinéma voir
parasites ou joker joker parvient à la
maison après un hiver on jase
pendant longtemps on french pendant une
demi-heure blondy crise m'excite plomb
fellah mots qui on commence bien
tranquillement vraiment leur nicoléon et
connectés ensemble
pigeât finalement en bout de ligne on
fait l'amour et du rien de bestiaire
rien d' intenses mais c'est beau puis
les deux on a capoté pour moi ça c'est
cette idée là est beaucoup plus
existantes intéressante que l'idée
d'être avec huit autres groupes finir sa
phrase une fille pour moi ça c'est
beaucoup plus proche d'une sexualité qui
m'intéresse pas propre nom d'une
sexualité qui m'intéresse mais regardez
ces vidéos le top la comicodi regarde
basque pascal un protégé de la première
manche où la sexualité
je dirais des gens mais leur sexualité
des fois sur des gones il faut définir
s'ils vont chercher du dans quelque
chose dans les deux mais un mondial
les deux sont possibles et je dirais
même que c'est pour ça que c'est
excitant les 8 go c'est ce que moi je
pense que cet excès pas autant que ça
n'existe pas tanxxx mais ce que je ne
serai pas taxe m'étais bien moralement
avec ce puits non je n'ai pas juste pour
bien paraître pas de casque non bien par
être moralement attentes intérieur même
l'impression qu'il ya dix jours le film
la pianiste le film la pianiste et un
film autrichien génial c'est sur le bdsm
est indigne désolé encore de 10 aix à la
fin c'est à la tripe sur du la violence
mais très très très très très très forte
à la fin du film parce que je répète mon
jeu construit à la fin du film
l'oeuvre à la fin du film se fait battre
et violée devant sa mère qu'elle avait
demandé au goût de farce mais à 5-4 ap
hm est traumatisé bien les thèmes selon
le philosophe du film s'il faut jamais
réaliser ses rêves
ils font fantasmer quelque chose mais
c'est mieux de le faire passer ma vie en
ce moment seulement par contre je vais
te dire faut que l'autre jour j'avais 7
ans 18 h 2 sur wii ça marche pas que les
filles doit être geek doit être guy
georges pas que les filles c'est à
l'intérieur je clique pouzac league
quand même franchi pour des gars 30 ans
c'est pas ça l'essayer c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça c'est pas normal qu'un
gâteau ce qu'ils pensent à des grosses
pour marc gautschi vraiment tellement
bien l'expérience techniquement
impeccable je peux pas nier ces 500 nuit
est à presque 100 gay quand tu fais un
orgasme milliers de fois je n'ai qu'un
globe
ouais mais bon moi ta main notamment pas
que tu n'es pas pour la fois que ce
n'était qu'un poisson mais est-ce que
vous pensez que problème problème avec
la avec la culture pornographiques ou ce
sera un problème non mais je suis le
film en question sont âprement canadiens
pensent et exige que ça met une pression
un peu phoque top sur les femmes
pis même même sur les hommes ces émeutes
ont été peints des jeunes le tout mon
soûl leur look et tout le monde vit
l'aise
on oublie que c'est ça avoir entre 17 et
22 ans tu vis une pression énorme de
devenir un adulte doit non mais pas mais
c'est ça à travers l'université sous une
pression énorme
le marché du travail c'est une pression
et demande à cet âge là les répressions
irréel c'est beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui vient des dépressions à l'université
déjà beaucoup d'universités mais tom et
on met donc je suis une jeune jeune
fille en ce moment de 14 ans puis c'est
sûr qu'il y en a qui écoute le podcast
puis qu'ils entendent dams un mois moi
je trouve quand même c'est de voir que
tu savais qu'ils vont puisque dans qui
pleure ou mais à quatorze ans de pac
2014 ne pas la mettre sur critique
sexuelle de peinture était alors que
prend ce discours en disant tous les
faux que je couche place ouais mais
comme la maintenir tout le monde a accès
à ce sont celles là il n'y a pas
personne qui font intrigue qui après un
petit clic pas sur wii quand elle a eu
18 ans et oui je devais être
impressionné par le ce que je trouve ces
problématiques de dire on a accès à sera
notre poche
puis c'est ça l'image la sexualité qu'on
donne à des gens qui l'ont peut-être
même pas expérimenté puis le
de voir je te demande ce que tu viens de
signer une feuille qui se met à pleurer
parce qu'elles sont trop profonds au
fond de la gorge
quant à 14 ans fait crise travaillent
sur le plat après cinquante et un goal
14 ans qui regardent ce je vais ce que
tu votes pour la première fois sera
mangé une table on nous ta première
blonde nous les filles qui fréquentent
le torrent t'attends à tous je trompé
les speed suffit il ya aussi ça y est
aussi que même ni tout ce que tu es dans
ta tête c'est pas de rêverie à blanc et
pas juste un mince et ce afin je vais
parce que si tout était conditionnée à
voir ce pic et là c'est comme une
feuille qui connaît pas trop sa
sexualité est placé à die ses erreurs le
tout voici tu fais tabarnak sais pas ce
que j'ai vu c'est pas ce que j'ai vu
mais m'a fait avoir à faire mais je suis
pas gay même calice jusqu'à vomir là
dessus je trouve que c'est problématique
à ce niveau là je veux dire moi je vais
regarder de la pornographie à savoir
très bien faire la différence entre ma
sexualité aps la sexualité que je
regarde je compris que dans la majorité
des cas sauf que dans la majorité des
cas les gens sont capables de faire la
différence entre la vraie vie ce qui
vaut être la vraie vie mais dans que des
jeux avec de gens jeunes c'est ça ou
dans le cas de certaines personnes
justement qui deviennent ça existe
dépendance à la pornographie ça existe
quand même
il disait c'est drôle c'était un accroc
la polygraphie parce que mettons qu'on
regarde des dépendances
oui on est accro à manger de ce papier
ou de croissance répétée crois moi je
dis papillon tels symptômes les plus
graves
s'il faut tout le temps que tu restes à
la maison et de toute nature tout le
temps ce pour la pornographie problème
secteur de quoi de plus probable c'est
que pour comme les comme tout dépendant
web à la sauge ou à la crème dans le jeu
c'était vraiment trop juste une question
d'argent tout vu gagner plus d'argent
il est accro à la cocaïne le jeu black
hawk et la cauquenne c'est physique ça
crée une dépendance
mais le jeu c'est atlus et psychologique
c'est une substance hauteur c'est la
même chose serait pas de refus
non je pense être un mois moi je pense
que les gens qui sont accros est en jeu
c'est pas une raison de la dispa une
question d'argent c'est le triste du jeu
c'est aussi très large c'est le même qui
croient joué mais tout ce que je fais
c'est gage epinal il joue tout à
l'argent
l'argentine saveur cette équation touche
bien c'est celle envie de gagner d'en
perdre tous ses amis des joueurs
compulsifs mon tour très demandé de
l'argent puis oui métier parce que c'est
la seule façon tu peux sourire ton désir
de jouer une question des risques là
dedans question de aussi de faire là la
chose qu'il faut pas femmes comme je
prenais graphique c'est moralement
répréhensible ou possible j'ai pas tout
de suite mais non mais la pornographie
c'est quand même quelque chose on en
parle sauf que c'est quand même quelque
chose que tout le monde consomme peu de
gens en parlent
la société seror que tu vois que tu
pénètres mais qu ils arrêtent tout cas
hadopi ça va parler de pornographie des
âmes regarde ça va te dis déjà on n'est
pas obligé de tunivisions que bien que
pénélope mcquade a décidé ce que les
gens disent qu est ce que je suis et je
pense qu'on se construit aussi
d'immigrants l'arcade prend le pas de
calais qui veulent le seroc et dans la
société
toutes ces décisions la passionnée
raison pourquoi pas la requête ou si
populaire c'est que paul arcand vous
recevoir 6 % dans la première la graphie
ils vont recevoir des pollutions qui en
parlait qu'en l'espace de quoi
pornographie tout le temps en avant par
les le fils denis coderre a été pris
parce qu'ils préfèrent des crédits pour
payer son plein gré la fille en a parlé
ouais je viens pas pour arc
ouais t'as pas que dire à part que c'est
un sujet d'actualité qui touchent
quelqu'un qui dans le monde de la
politique
ok mais jamais personne qui va des
actifs via le nouveau vidéo de la
démarche éthique et ça c'est mon papa
nos erreurs que mon gentil c'est
d'ailleurs ma tête ma blonde ça va pas
dire que c'est moralement répréhensible
je fais la même chose que dans c'est une
question aussi de moeurs en disant voici
comment j'ai pris ma blonde ce matin par
contre quand je crois que ma blonde n'a
pas peur mais quoi ma blonde sexy
c'est aussi une question de murs et de
parler tout le temps ça c'est vrai je
dire parce que là on n'en parle pas car
ça existe de vous à chaque semaine vous
êtes très très très puissant vous avez
des décodeurs aux artistes a déjà qui
vous écoute vous avez une influence et
puis je rigolais pas moralement
répréhensible non ce wee cc le boulou
sérieusement je crois que je vais
regarder s coiffe info cette posture 10
à 20 kg jacques une période déjà avec
est large plus 6 autres équipes de sport
qui diffuse les équipes de sport le si
on a parlé beaucoup de décès à faire le
tout ce qu'il reste comme si on était
des experts en la matière mais personne
c'est justement été en son temps puis
moulin venise mais j'avais dit au groupe
le que je n'ai pas été très beaux
bourgognes explique je viens pas il y
avait un domaine à l'export y est-il
était pluvieux et frais comme de simples
viennoiseries lui grâce à bord du poil
sépia elle devenir un homme s'était
moqué de moi mais c'était moitié moins
vite et m puis simple et malley et mène
à l'étonnement est retraité depuis 111
ans on a un gars après puberté
m'investis à jalalabad
c'est extra j'adore ce moment là ta vie
hu monsieur même machine à remonter dans
le temps j'irai pas tuer hitler
j'irai dans ce vestiaire et je serais
arrêté parce que j'ai 30 ans et sa
machine à remonter dans le temps à la
bordeaux pour des crimes sexuels qui ne
regardent même j'avoue y en avait eu des
fois des salades et des messieurs ouais
on espère que ça les temps changent
il ya des gars est ce qu'il ya des
manants qui fonde les photos ça tu joues
et que le rongeur est extrêmement
populaire à attirer des fonds pas du
tout le rouge et or lâche pas et que le
football
quelque chose que avec le succès du
rouge et or le propre de football après
plus d'expansion des commanditaires
alors tout tout tout le lait halle
sportive de liberté la marge brute oui
grâce le super peps le super peps ccc
50% la ville j'ai 50 c'était pas 50 mail
à del contribuent beaucoup super peps
l'université l'autre partie mais
l'université laval c'est vraiment
faisait déjà de 2 go rouge et or
football escrocs pour les autres mais
les vieux vestiaires gens seuls très bon
niveau
on y à l'époque parenté comme un sous
sol
lego raciste et à 12,1 me rendant son
peuple qui est un peu de bois noble
non sans rappeler les bonnes âmes ce qui
respire fort
[Rires]
selon les trucs trop relax dans son nom
était vulgaire pour l'aider c'est ce que
ce qui me fait rire quand ils
interdisent des oeuvres à des enfants en
surpoids seraient un plus trop vulgaire
ya pas plus vulgaire qu'un garçon de
onze ans ont tellement faux soit jusqu'à
discussions dans tout sur la
pornographie
à ce moment le team nous mettons pour
avoir un contact avec avec la
pornographie s'apprenait j'en fais le tu
l'autre des images
or sur l'essai donnait une image sur la
moyenne des phoques ingleby puis puis
maintenant mais n'imagine dans mon
cellulaire je suis pour le ton pénis
d'un homme à cause la première affiche
mais comme imagine fait jusqu'à notre
jeunesse on aurait eu dans nos poches un
instrument avec comme seule limite notre
imagination
et comme tout dans la vie on serait
passé à autre chose
ce qui est particulier quand ils donnent
leur donne l'accès à quelqu'un c'est
bien des gens qui dit aux mosquées 20
pianos schiele jurés joue du piano tout
le temps non non je jouis deux semaines
je crois que oui déjà qu'ils virent
foulon et téléphone durant un rectangle
magique dans l'eure dans leur poche
qu'ils font qui fait qu'ils peuvent tout
le temps pour la première il a fait bien
reviennent pas mais ça ça reste un
produit d'un espace de des problèmes là
je temporise lost a vu lever encore la
sexualité c'est différent bien mais bien
des gens et des gens qui se passe au bon
soin par jour peas lily compte ça va
très très bien leur vie elle expose une
fois par semaine ça va bien leur vie ce
qui est malheureux dans ce discours
lancer car une sexualité parfaire une
sexualité qu'il faudrait atteindre c'est
faux et c'est ce qu'il fonde la
pornographie je crois est ce que les
choses s'étaient un peu brillant de la
pornographie il ya plein de catégories
ya plein de sortes de sexualité c'est un
des messages que tu peut capter la
pornographie c'est beau c'est beau
mais ces bonnes valeurs j'y crois
vraiment je crois même que la
pornographie pour les filles c'est même
- - - plats témoins dérangeait moins ça
fait moins de complexes que la mode
parce que la mode ya un genre de fille
encore c'est taille telle dimension la
pornographie tous les dimensions sont de
la graphie c'est beaucoup beaucoup cmj
inclusif la province inclusif c'était
des tentacules
c'est beaucoup plus dans la dentelle
dans l'art populaire c'est tout le temps
hétérosexuels que si ces homosexuels
c'est pas trop beau pour faut pas trop
qui s'embrassent dans la pornographie
théorique avant la graphie aux affaires
des graffitis que c'est un petit fils de
14 ans pour s'y voir des filles
s'embrassent pas ce thème souvent des
filles qui s'embrassent de pâques cesse
avec ses normale et excités par les
faits moi je croyais que je t'ai pas
normal fallait que je sois obligé des
milliers si c'était mais c'est oublier
voir ça bien des gens qui voient la
culture populaire qui je dois être
obligés d'être hétérosexuel où je vais
être obligée à voir faire l'amour à deux
bien des gens qui font qu'on soit 4
n'est pas catherine paul biya moyens que
la sexualité ce soit si tu peux faire
l'amour à 4 faire l'amour à 8
ça c'est sûr complexée c'est un bon
point tout à fait comment merci par jour
grâce à un excellent on en a aux gens de
vivre dans mes chouchous le 25 janvier à
montréal près d'eux
c'est l'instinct samedi se veut national
je vais parler beaucoup de temps c'est
quoi j'ai pas de tente jour de
masturbation avec du matériel - icône un
bouclier enfin chaud mercredi une soirée
d'humour qui commence à partir de
février à l'hémisphère gauche venait me
voir je les ai vus depuis deux mois on
va les faire un numéro qui ont mon
numéro est prêt mais c'est ok la c4 est
pas trop un des deux que plus on trie
pas trop claude embarque les premiers
pas une bonne
c'est brillant pour vous c'est l'idée de
faire du stand up me terrifie un point
ultime sortie en zone de confort
ouais ouais ça fait rire ce expression
là parce que j'ai jamais été confortable
de ma vie j'aurais été terrifiée oui à
la banque ça me suffit à la l'épicerie
j'ai vu le deuxième stage animé une
soirée improvisée avec le public aurait
deux temps
tout le monde rit de mon iphone est
comme un poisson dans l'eau tout juste
mais le taf à moi j'ai l'impression que
j'arriverai lopssi serait un poisson
dans le désert qui met c'est pas moi qui
ai mais j'ai beaucoup de défauts mais je
suis pas misogyne source dans la vie
tous les jours je suis misogyne mais pas
sur 100 sinon on écoute ton podcast le
souhaitais pas de cas si je me dis que
vous aimez pas de casse ce même témoin
et un bac à skis et enregistre ici au
studio sfr puis je juge ou venir
merci pour votre habitation je ne mérite
pas merci souvenir est absolument
merci beaucoup puis un salut tout le
monde y est ça va de chinois surfent eux
on voit plus les bananes sont pas tant
est qu'on n'a pas bien fait les game on
préfère aussi parce que c'est bon pour
nous les petits rouler le débat
si les 10 baptistes rôle débit on
l'appelle des bébés bienvenue au sein
fait